in a frantic and sort of apoplectic
attempt to take attention away from the
daily scandals and the plummeting
approval ratings the Trump White House
has now put together a whole schedule of
themed weeks that no one actually cares
about it's completely silly but lots of
the week directly conflict with what
Donald Trump and his family are doing
and my favorite is they've now unveiled
made in America week and the idea is
they're going to promote the
manufacturing of products in the United
States
unfortunately this directly contradicts
Donald Trump's own business practices
Ivanka Trump's own business practices
Donald Trump has outsourced production
of his stuff of very serious things that
he produces to any number of countries
everything from home decor to men's
clothing remember this classic
cringe-worthy incident on the David
Letterman Show as a line of clothing no
where were these made these were made I
don't know where they were made but they
were made someplace but they're great
its ties shirts cufflinks everything
sold at Macy's and they're doing great
number one selling tie anywhere in the
world number one cell at a tie anywhere
in the world is your you wouldn't wear
that you also have them in white and
beautiful why are the shirts made
Bangladesh what is good we employ people
in Bangladesh it is where the ties it
was a beautiful ties they are great ties
are made in where China has invaded
China yeah and it's not just Trump
Trump's daughter who sat in for Trump
the other day at the g20 at a table of
world leaders her clothing line is
exclusively manufactured in other
countries by low-wage workers in what I
guess I would call questionable
conditions including Indonesia and
Bangladesh and China a specific target
of Trump
there have been 2,000 shipments of stuff
and things from other countries since
2010 for Ivanka's products that have
come to the u.s. how many American jobs
could that manufacturing have provided
and asked at Sunday's briefing whether
made in America would include a
commitment from Trump and Ivanka Trump
to make their products in the United
States
reporters were told quote we'll get back
to you
that I just think that Trump eschews
this it's sort of like how he finds
himself to be the best person to six
corruption in Washington right because
as a businessman he bought politicians
or that he's the one that can reform the
tax code because he was able to use the
loopholes to his advantage I just I
don't see this really sticking now who
definitely support him no matter what
you're right it's total cognitive
dissonance from the trumpets last time I
criticized the Trump's for this people
wrote to me defending them saying David
these are business people they can't
change the fact that it's cheaper
elsewhere they're just operating within
the business environment they didn't
create the business environment I'm sure
if it was just as cheap in the u.s. of
course that they'd manufacture here I'm
probably being overly charitable here in
terms of the eloquence of these people
who wrote to me I'm skipping the words
Jew and cuck from my recollections of
what these messages said when they were
written to me but that's the idea
does that make sense to anyone we're
talking about a billionaire here he can
just afford to make a little bit less
money on this nonsense and produce it in
the United States sir it certainly
doesn't make him sound like a leader now
does it you know even just because
everyone else is doing it doesn't mean
that he has to stoop to that level as
well absolutely pathetic and every
single one of these themed weeks they're
just hilarious I mean every single one
is either representative of some kind of
projection or it just makes no sense
they're just childish distractions from
the endless scandals send me your
thoughts about this I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman we'll be back right after the
break